réaliser le virage chinois.
(applaudissements)
- Il entre dans l'histoire.
Xi Jinping, l'homme politique
chinois le plus puissant
depuis Mao, sort de ce congrès
renforcé et incontesté.
"Le monde est aux prises avec
des défis sans précédent",
soutient-il.
Pour la première fois
en 25 ans, ae e e femme n'accède
au bureau politique, les hautes
sphères du pouvoir chinois.
Sept hommes au sommet,
le comité permanent.
Dans la nouvelle garde
rapprochée de Xi Jinping,
la loyauté prime.
Les quatre nouveaux venus sont
tous fidèles au président
autoritaire. Le ieieier ministre
et le vice-premier ministre
actuels sont écartés.
Problème de santé ou message
politique, l'ancien président,
Hu Jintao avait été poussé luia.
ROBERT DUJARRIC, départ. études
asiatiques, Univ. Temple, Tokyo
- Fondamentalement,
P P Parti communiste chinois et
un parti d'origine soviétique.
Ça mène très souvent vers
une concentration totale
du pouvoir dans les mains
d'un homme. On l'a vu avec Mao,
on l'a vu avec Staline.
- Li Qiangrararait obtenir
le poste de premier ministre.
Ce responsable du Parti
communiste à Shanghai est celui
qui avait imposé le confinement
rigide de deux mois le printemps
der.r.r. La politique sanitaire
a soulevé la grogne populaire;
les commerçants peinent encore
à se remettre du chaos.
"L'économie chie e e est dotée
d'une grande résilience
et d'un fort potentiel,
répond-il, ses solides bases
ne changeront pas."
Taïwan devient une priorité
absolue pour le Parti communiste
chinois. La garde rapprochée
de Xi Jinping est composée
de parti d d de la ligne dure
envers l'île que la Chine
considère comme une province
rebelle.
Le Parti communiste chinois
a même adopté une résolution
samedi affirmant la nécess
de combattre et de freiner
toutes les tentatives prônant
l'indépendance de Taïwan.
ANTOINE BONDAZ, chercheur, Fond.
pour la recherche stratégique
- Du côté de Taïwan, il faut
donc se préparer le mieux
possible au scénario du pire
sur le plan militaire et essayer
ououout faire pour dissuader
la Chine de changer
le statu quo.
- Politique zéro COVID
contraignante, ralentissement
de l'économie, taux de chômage
de 20 % chez les jeunes,
tensions avec les États-Unis
et l'Europe; les défononont
pressants et nombreux pour
la Chine de Xi Jinping.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Taipei.